Pam what's your relationship like now
with Tommy are you are you in touch with
him at all or uh do you just kind of I
mean text here and there you know
nothing nothing too crazy I mean he's
married and and happy and she's good to
him and I I totally support that and
think that's great so I mean I hate to
be annoying and going through this again
and for sure she's annoyed but
um I respect their relationship and just
glad he's happy and he has somebody in
his life do your boys like him or are
they estranged they do they like him no
they they see him all the time they see
him all the time and I think that this
movie too is kind of like a love letter
to their parents they know they come
from True Love they want people to see
the real story and I thought that was
kind of cute and kind of charming and
and really you know Brandon um is very
artistic and really wanted to show the
story from
they're my real true authentic
perspective it was really it was really
well done and and I enjoyed it sometimes
I I found myself going I wonder if I
said to Pam well do you have any regrets
like do you think there were certain
things in life or would you just do it
all over the same exact way was it was
it a fun ride or was there there was
there was a tragic or miserable what how
do you assess it it was all of it but it
was more good times than bad and
um
yeah I wouldn't do it any other way I
mean I just feel like it was just this
wild wild ride and I made it home in one
piece I came back to the place I grew up
in I bought the house of my grandmother
and I'm living in it and I'm looking at
my life from the same place my feet
touched the ground when I was a baby I
mean I'm right I look at it all like a
movie
foreign